[Musik]
spinnst du nicht mehr umbringen oder was
ja sag mal Gasper das ist aber nicht
gesund was du da machst bist du mir
Wurst ich muss weiter aber du bist nicht
fit das sehe ich gleich schau mich an
alles Muskeln und zusammen Strahlen
weißt du was bei dir ist ich glaube du
hast total beschissene live work Balance
knackig hat das bringt überhaupt nicht
schau dich doch mal an aber ich gehe
jeden Mittwoch abend geht zum Wilderer
ja dann die ganze Tag refressen oder was
also nach 18 Uhr ist sie grundsätzlich
nichts mehr und kohlenhydrahtlose
grundsätzlich Weg hey du bist voll von
vorgestern weißt du was du brauchst du
brauchst du unbedingt
fitnessuhr schau ja wie total super
fitnessuhr
du musst alles die Mist Schrift
verstehst die Mist Blutdruck und vor
allem Kraft in die Eier
und das geht alles mit Satellit geht es
an die beste Ärzte von die ganze Welt
und die rufen dich dann an und sagen hey
gratuliere du hast fitness-urs und
Seiten begann ich angerufen
Sensation
mache ich dir super Angebot heute mache
ich waldpreis kriegst du für 250 Euro
und dazu kriegst du auch noch echte Bund
zu Handtuch mit original Schweiß von
echte Champion
also weiß jetzt gar nicht was ich sagen
soll okay Mann
[Applaus]
braucht jemand flache ist frisch von die
Jäger gefallen